aujourd'hui mardi 16 décembre il est 18h
si vous nous rejoignez en direct sur
tvfils bonsoir et bienvenue voici les
titres de ce journal l'université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
présentées en conseil d'administration
ce mardi son budget pour 2015 un budget
à l'équilibre après la crise traversée
l'année dernière pour y parvenir des
concessions réalisées sur les dépenses
les étudiants dont guère apprécié une
manifestation a été organisée et le vote
reporté table ronde dans quelques heures
à Voisins le bretonneux autour du
plateau de Saclay qu'apportera ce
cluster scientifique et technologique au
développement de l'agglomération de
Versailles Saint-Quentin nous en
parlerons dans un instant avec Dominique
Vernet le président de la fondation de
coopération scientifique Paris-Saclay et
puis le jour de Noël approche vos
cadeaux sont-ils prêts nous irons sur le
marché de Noël de Voisins le bretonneux
et nous verrons aussi comment s'organise
la poste pour vous faire parvenir dans
les temps vos colis malgré ce rush de
fin d'année
les élus régionaux qui vont plancher dès
demain et durant en trois jours sur le
budget 2015 un budget qui selon les
socialistes à la tête de l'institution
mais l'accent sur les investissements
notamment dans les transports
négociations autour du Pass Navigo à
tarif unique oblige ce mardi matin lors
de sa conférence de presse le président
Jean-Paul Huchon a aussi évoqué les 425
millions d'euros pour la construction et
la rénovation des lycées ou encore les 5
millions pour améliorer l'offre de soins
de son côté son opposant tu MP et
candidate déjà en campagne pour lui
succéder en décembre 2015 Valérie
Pécresse a déclaré qu'en cas de victoire
aux élections elle présenterait la
facture du Pass Navigo à tarif unique au
Premier ministre Manuel Valls sa
priorité restant le développement
économique je vous propose d'écouter les
deux protagonistes
rien c'est dire qui est présent sur tous
les grands secteurs d'investissement de
la région on n'a pas baissé
l'investissement au contraire
le budget augmente
on est par ailleurs maintenant
en mesure de recevoir les fonds
européens et de les gérer donc ça permet
de faire un peu plus un peu mieux en
matière de fonctionnement du légèrement
recul c'est la preuve du sérieux de
notre gestion qui est souligné
d'ailleurs par la Cour des comptes d'un
côté les agences
de notation de l'autre donc c'est un
budget
je dirais qui prépare l'avenir et qui
conforte notre rôle essentiel en matière
d'aménagement du territoire de transport
d'éducation et de formation je crois
qu'aujourd'hui on est face à une
situation inédite le chômage augmente
plus vite en Île-de-France que partout
ailleurs et aujourd'hui on a un vrai
sujet d'insertion professionnelle des
jeunes donc moi je prendrai tous les
crédits qui sont non prioritaires et je
les affecterai assez compétences
développement économique aide aux
entreprises en difficulté
formation professionnelle des chômeurs
formation professionnelle des jeunes
apprentissage et c'est ce sera ma
priorité et ma deuxième priorité ce sera
de lutter contre toutes ces fractures
territoriales en Île-de-France il y a
des quartiers qui sont des quartiers
délaissés j'affecterai une partie des
recettes d'investissement à la desserte
de transport de la grande couronne et
puis au contrat ruraux pour la période
les quartiers périurbains ambiance de
pré campagne électorale entre les deux
opposants rappelons que dans les
sondages Valérie Pécresse arrive en tête
des intentions de vote mais il reste un
an avant le scrutin l'université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin en Yvelines 20
000 étudiants et seulement 23 ans l'an
dernier confronté à la logique
implacable des dépenses en hausse et des
recettes à la traîne l'établissement a
été placé sous tutelle de l'État et sous
perfusion également cette année le
budget proposé au vote en conseil
d'administration était à l'équilibre
mais il a fallu faire des économies les
étudiants qui n'ont pas vraiment
apprécié ils ont manifesté aujourd'hui
reportage d'Anthony Rey chez de William
elle
après un an d'austérité l'université de
Versailles 50 ans en Yvelines s'apprête
à voter un budget à l'équilibre pourtant
les stigmates de la rigueur sont encore
présents la filière STAPS a fermé plutôt
que prévu la fac de droit n'imprime plus
de polycopié les étudiants craignent à
terme la dévalorisation de leur diplôme
sur le marché du travail en sortant
d'université en déficit et en 2015 que
les taux ne se desserrent pas pour
donner un exemple le gvt le glissement
vieille technique donc ce qui fait que
les fonctionnaires plus travaillent des
années plus ont d'expérience plus
gainants salaires en fait l'état ne
s'engage à ne payer que 40% de ce de ce
glissement vieille technique du coup
c'est aux universités sur leur fonds
propres de devoir assumer les 60% du
coup pour avoir un budget à l'équilibre
elles sont obligés de couper dans les
autres budgets dont la formation par
exemple en 2015 il y aura moins de place
pour les étudiants dans les formations
en Licence ou en Master et c'est pas
nous payer les pots cassés pour
protester contre ce vote de budget
prévisionnel cette vingtaine d'étudiants
s'apprêtent à entrer deux forces dans la
salle de réunion du conseil
d'administration
après une quinzaine de minutes passées
dans la salle de réunion les étudiants
ressortent du bâtiment de l'université
avec le sentiment de la mission
accomplie mais ce serait heurté au refus
de dialogue de la direction on est
rentré à l'intérieur de ce conseil
d'administration et tout de suite le
président de l'université à tout de
suite hurlé il y avait des membres du
cousin administration qui hurlaient des
membres élus quand même des gens qui
sont censés garder leur canne pour
pouvoir discuter posément on n'est pas
rentré on est rentré ici de manière un
petit peu rude mais à l'intérieur c'est
juste posé autour faut juste pouvoir
discuter on avait tous préparé des
choses à dire pour pouvoir en débattre
avec eux exprimer les craintes des
étudiants n'ont même pas voulu les
entendre ils ont préféré annuler la
séance pour nous faire passer pour des
gens violents la démarche de ces
étudiants s'inscrit dans un mouvement
national contre la baisse de dotation de
l'État pour l'enseignement supérieur le
vote du budget 2015 de l'université et
donc repoussé à une date ultérieure pas
encore connue
invité de ce 16 décembre du journal
Dominique Vernet bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes le président de la
fondation de coopération scientifique
Paris Saclay ce soir à
Voisins-le-Bretonneux en mairie va se
tenir des 20h30 une table ronde une
discussion avec pour thème les enjeux du
développement lié à ce cluster Paris
Saclay une question pointue austère
peut-être qui a pourtant beaucoup
d'importance pour l'avenir même du
territoire de 50 ans en Yvelines alors
on va commencer par faire un peu de
pédagogie votre mission c'est d'assurer
le succès du Campus Paris Saclay le
Campus Paris Saclay c'est quoi ça
correspond à quoi alors ça correspond à
quoi l'ambition je vais parler de
l'ambition bah cette créer l'équivalent
d'une grande université comme Cambridge
comme Oxford sur le territoire de Paris
Saclay pourquoi parce que finalement on
est à l'ère de la mondialisation et il
faut être visible et il faut être
visible à l'instar des grandes
universités que j'ai cités je
rajouterais Harvard et le MIT et
d'autres et pour attirer les meilleures
étudiants pour assurer les meilleurs
professeurs pour naturels les meilleurs
enseignants chercheurs il faut être
visible mondialement mais c'est aussi
pour attirer des entreprises des
entreprises qui se disent j'ai besoin de
personnalités j'ai besoin de transfert
technologique ou vais-je installer mon
nouveau centre de R&D et bien ce qu'on
souhaite c'est qu'il s'installe sur
territoire Paris Saclay qui inclut bien
sûr de 50 ans aujourd'hui un tel
équipement un tel ensemble ça n'existe
pas en France vous parlez de faire
l'équivalent d'arvard l'équivalent en
France ça n'existe pas et en fait il
faudrait remonter assez loin mais en
fait le paysage académique français est
extrêmement
fractionné
et quand on prend concrètement Paris
Saclay en fait c'est 19 établissements
d'enseignement supérieur de recherche et
de et de recherche ce sont deux
universités universités de Paris-Sud et
université du SQ Versailles
Saint-Quentin c'est une dizaine de
grandes écoles école d'ingénieurs École
Normale Supérieure école de commerce
c'est aussi cette organisme de recherche
vous voyez ça fait beaucoup dans
d'autres pays on connaît qu'une seule
notion c'est l'université qui rassemble
l'ensemble de ses composantes un
changement de mentalité aussi
on va parler avec ce Paris Saclay d'un
pôle scientifique et technologique c'est
donc un cluster le fameux cluster ça a
été lancé concrètement un petit peu
avant 2010 au niveau des années 2000 on
en est aujourd'hui de se développements
de Paris Saclay alors d'abord au niveau
universitaire je parlerai près de la
partie développement du cluster en fait
au cœur d'un cluster des grands clusters
il y a toujours une grande université et
donc nous on fabrique cette grande
université et la fondation de
coopération scientifique que je préside
en fait elle a été créée en 2007 et à
l'époque c'était pour gérer je dirais
des projets transverses pour des
physiciens pour des personnes qui
travaillent cette technologie
d'information et puis petit à petit
effectivement cet esprit de
rassemblement a parcouru d'autres
communautés académiques et très con en
2000 en 2011 à l'occasion d'un appel à
projet qui avait été lancé par l'État au
titre des investissements d'avenir le
fameux Grand Emprunt et bien nous avons
été sélectionnés pour créer cette
université Paris-Saclay on a reçu une
dotation de pratiquement un milliard
d'euros en c'est une dotation non
consensive on utilise les intérêts c'est
la première fois qu'un telfinancement
existe en France et ça ressemble
beaucoup d'ailleurs au financement des
fondations des grandes universités à
l'étranger voilà donc déjà un mécanisme
de financement qui qui ressemble et
concrètement nous attendons aujourd'hui
enfin vraiment dans les jours qui
viennent le décret qui porte la création
d'université Paris-Saclay et à ce
moment-là qui existera légalement
ce sont les universités que vous avez
mentionnés les grands ensembles qui vont
fusionner en fait c'est université
fédérale c'est-à-dire que nous allons
avoir un ensemble qui va être qui va
comprendre alors l'Université fédérale
elle respecte les identités de chacune
de chacun des membres par contre ils
acceptent de se fédérer de sous
l'autorité finalement d'une direction
unique et en fait c'est l'unité c'est la
fonte c'est la l'université Paris-Saclay
qui va délivrer tous les diplômes
universitaires
doctorat Master et à terme la licence
par contre les écoles elles conservent
leur diplôme qui est pas diplôme
national mais un diplôme spécifique en
profitant de l'Université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin par exemple
c'est même un diplôme de l'université
paris-saclets d'accord il sera plus
diplômé de Versailles Saint-Quentin sera
diplômé de Paris Saclay donc ça on est
sur les bases les explications de ce
projet Paris-Saclay quels sont les
enjeux pour le territoire parce que
c'est le but de la réunion de la table
ronde qui se tiendra tout à l'heure à
Voisins-le-Bretonneux à partir de 20h30
donc ce mardi dans quelques heures si
vous nous suivez ce soir en direct
l'objectif c'est quoi l'enjeu pour 50
ans en Yvelines c'est quoi l'enjeu c'est
d'abord la visibilité internationale je
bon Versailles Saint-Quentin en Yvelines
ça a beaucoup de mérites mais bon
Versailles connu par son château mais
pas forcément important
en Île-de-France c'est déjà moins connu
dans la France et honnêtement dès qu'on
va à l'étranger c'est pas forcément très
connu donc l'objectif c'est que ce
territoire soit repéré comme un grand
territoire de développement et que dans
le fond des entreprises étrangères
qu'elle puisse américaine asiatique qui
se disent j'ai envie de m'installer en
Europe
où est-ce que je vais m'installer je
vais m'installer un endroit où il y a
des gens formés ou il y a encore des
réserves foncières pour mettre mes
bâtiments où il y a tout qui est prévu
pour accueillir les entreprises et bien
ça fait partie de l'objectif du cluster
c'est d'attirer finalement des nouvelles
entreprises c'est une manière de de
créer de du développement économique de
l'emploi c'est qui est effectivement de
nouvelles entreprises qui investissent
dans notre territoire composanta
importante c'est l'université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin consiste depuis
tout à l'heure à d'autres pays tout à
l'heure au cours de cette discussion on
a aussi vu il y a quelques instants en
reportage qui parlaient du budget et des
difficultés rencontrées les années
précédentes le budget qui n'a pas été
voté aujourd'hui même s'il est à
l'équilibre mais les étudiants
s'inquiètent il y a eu donc un report du
vote après une mobilisation
manifestation qu'elle regarde vous
portez sur la situation économique
actuelle de l'université est-ce qu'il y
a matière à son inquiéter est-ce que
vous vous en inquiétez tout en tout
simplement je pense qu'on peut jamais
être tout à fait rassuré bon
effectivement université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin qui est une grande
université en 20 000 étudiants
1000 professeurs enseignants chercheurs
bon c'est une université qui
effectivement a quelques problèmes
économiques maintenant quand on regarde
en termes de pourcentage c'est quand
même pas énorme c'est une fraction et
d'après son président que j'ai rencontré
encore récemment Jean-Luc Bessières
l'équilibre et est très proche voilà
ce qui est clair c'est que l'université
Paris Saclay va pouvoir constituer une
solution alors pourquoi pour deux
raisons d'abord parce qu'on va
mutualiser en mutualise des formations
mutualise des moyens ça veut dire des
économies ça veut dire quelque part
économie ou à budget constant c'est de
meilleures investissements voilà une
meilleure formation pour les étudiants
c'est véritablement l'objectif de la
création Université Paris Saclay c'est
d'aller dans les deux sens c'est à la
mutualisé à la fois pour économiser sur
les budgets parce qu'on est dans un
univers contraint et c'est clair que le
poids
le poids pour le budget de la France est
très important il faut le reconnaître
donc on peut pas le monter de manière
infinie par contre il y a mieux à faire
en utilisant les moyens qui existent
déjà et nous avons aussi l'intention je
dirais d'associer des entreprises à
certaines formations à certains
développements dans interne université
Paris-Saclay ce qui permettra de
compléter par le chapitre des ressources
propres les les financements qui
arrivent directement de l'État vous
dites il y a mieux à faire ça veut dire
que l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines vous allez la
contraindre à changer un petit peu les
orientations les formations qui sont
proposées j'ai pas de contraindre
honnêtement mais c'est dans leur intérêt
malgré tout c'est de leur faire
comprendre collectif et l'université
Versailles
et
associés à toutes les décisions que nous
prenons c'est pas un système
hiérarchique c'est un système beaucoup
plus collégial dans lequel chacune des
voies est entendues et vous savez comme
moi qu'on ne contraint pas le système
universitaire il faut sur les formations
proposées il peut y avoir des
réorientations par exemple sur les axes
alors je vais donner deux exemples aussi
bien le doctorat que le master quand on
fait la somme je dirais des en
particulier des Masters qui existaient
sur l'ensemble Paris Saclay c'était tout
à fait astronomique c'est en tous les
cas absolument pas lisible là après un
gros travail faire collectivement fait
par les enseignants chercheurs eux-mêmes
c'est-à-dire ceux qui font les
formations et bien on est passé
on a réduit une manière considérable on
a une carte avec 49
masters et je crois de l'ordre de 350
parcours mais dans lequel Versailles
Saint-Quentin est associé
systématiquement avec d'autres
établissements sur chacune des
formations donc c'est véritablesment une
énorme transformation et l'idée c'est
que en portant à plusieurs des
formations elles seront plus reconnues
et puis
elle permettront d'avoir plus
d'étudiants par parcours et finalement
ça veut dire que c'est comme
économiquement meilleur voilà les enjeux
les objectifs de ce pari sacré de ce
campus Paris Saclay en tout cas tout à
l'heure il en sera question à 20h30 en
salle du conseil municipal de
Voisins-le-Bretonneux vous y serez
présent il y aura aussi des
représentants politiques des
représentants du Medef aussi par exemple
à qui s'adresse cette réunion le but
c'est de faire comprendre au grand
public ce qu'est Paris-Saclay ou ça va
être une réunion pour les initier tout à
l'heure justement alors moi j'espère que
ce sera pas pour les initiés parce que
les initiés connais et c'est même assez
triste parce qu'on est amené à redire un
peu différent la même chose parce que il
y a assez souvent des opposants et on
s'échange un peu les mêmes arguments je
crois que il y a un besoin d'en
connaître de la part de tous les
citoyens et j'espère qu'il y aura
effectivement des des nouveaux venus et
qui nous posons des questions parce que
c'est beaucoup de mélange qui peuvent
être fait aussi dans l'opinion parce
qu'on parle beaucoup d'ouverture des
intercommunalités plus larges on parle
de l'Opération d'Intérêt nationale on
parle de Paris Saclay on parle de
rapprochement entre les deux dans le
cadre de mutualisation de moyens
aujourd'hui c'est difficile de s'y
retrouver et de voir quels sont les
vrais enjeux et quand tout cela va enfin
être lisible pour le grand public
j'allais dire que les je crois que les
enjeux tout le monde les comprend c'est
donner de la compétitivité à la France
donner la compétitivité
aujourd'hui parce que est-ce qu'il y a
plusieurs solutions qui s'affrontent
est-ce que aujourd'hui finalement il y a
un consensus pour que ça aille dans le
bon sens j'allais dire que sur la partie
que je connais le mieux c'est-à-dire la
partie rassemblée des universités les
grandes écoles et les organismes de
recherche on est arrivé à consensus ça a
demandé du temps ça a été un peu
chaotique au départ mais on y est arrivé
maintenant ce qu'il s'agit c'est que les
collectivités territoriales face à la
même chose voilà donc on se pose pas du
tout en donneur de leçon parce qu'on
sait que chaque dans chaque institution
il y a des il y a des difficultés qui
peuvent qui sont inhérentes à chacune et
ses professions à chaque mais à chacun
met effectivement je crois qu'il y a
quand même la leçon c'est si on veut
exister au niveau mondial il faut qu'on
soit solidaire il faut qu'on travaille
beaucoup mieux ensemble je prends
souvent l'analogie des hors de Gauloises
on sait que finalement chacune était
peut-être très très forte mais prise
collectivement l'était pas et l'objectif
c'est véritablement et bien de
travailler ensemble ce que savent mieux
faire d'autres peuples et d'autres pays
voilà c'est tout le l'enjeu de cette
venue en plateau ce soir juste avant
cette réunion cette table ronde à 20h30
à voisin le Bretonneux pourrait évoquer
ce dossier du Paris Saclay merci à vous
une dernière information dans le domaine
de la haute technologie à vous donner
puisque une convention a été signée ce
matin entre RDF et le syndicat d'énergie
des Yvelines et orange pour
l'installation de la fibre optique dans
le département l'opérateur pourra ainsi
utiliser les ouvrages électriques
aériens de RDF 77 communes seront
concernées dont les clés sous bois
Coignières mord pas et plaisir écoutez
alors aujourd'hui la fibre dans les
Yvelines c'est plus de 100 000 logements
desservis par la fibre orange
c'est-à-dire la fibre passe dans la rue
c'est presque 70 000 logements
raccordables c'est-à-dire les fibres et
sur le palier ou à quelques mètres des
pavillons sur 50 ans donc sur la
casquille plusieurs communes sont
prévues au programme et donc nous allons
discuter avec
les responsables de la casqui pour voir
dans quelles conditions nous pouvons
déployer cette cette fibre le calendrier
c'est 2015 2016 il y a un coût
d'accélérateur et donc nous nous savons
que nous allons avoir de nombreux
chantiers sur sur nos réseaux donc nous
nous sommes prêts à accueillir la fibre
sur sur nos ouvrages et puis après je
pense que ça va continuer c'est aller
sur sur 2018 encore
nous ouvrons maintenant une large page
dédiée à Noël avec les achats sur
Internet nous sommes de plus en plus
nombreux à recevoir nos colis par la
poste et cela se multiplie forcément
pendant cette période de fêtes à
quelques jours du réveillon c'est le
rush dans les centres de distribution
comme à Bois-d'Arcy Mélanie pocket et le
dimone qui se sont levés aux aurores
pour ce reportage
dans ces cartons des cadeaux de Noël en
cette période très spéciale l'agence
colis la poste de Bois-d'Arcy en reçoit
plus de 20 000 par jour
et qu'on lâche tout au reste de l'année
on reçoit nos camions de façon anticipée
il y a des heures supplémentaires qui
sont faites par les postiers et puis des
prestataires qui nous aident aussi pour
cette période en période normale 80
véhicules partent chaque matin pour
desservir 44 communes des Yvelines peu
avant Noël ce sont jusqu'à 120 camions
qui livrent pour gérer le flux les
postiers commencent leur journée à 5
heures Baptiste brémo lui livre sur le
secteur Chambourcy Saint-Germain une
tournée un peu particulière puisque les
destinataires sont des entreprises
aujourd'hui Baptiste brémo a 160 colis à
livrer
pour pouvoir partir un peu plus tôt et
oui oui en terme de en termes de colis
on en a pour pas le double d'habitude
mais pas loin des fois donc oui oui ça
se ressent bien 6000 colis peuvent ainsi
être livrés sur une seule matinée rien
qu'à Versailles le pic d'activité de
l'agence de Bois-d'Arcy est attendu
demain histoire que les colis arrivent
attend au du sapin
après la vente en ligne les marchés de
Noël deuxième marché de Noël des
Yvelines celui est proposé à Voisins le
bretonneux s'est déroulé le week-end
dernier c'est donc un rendez-vous
important majeur pour le département les
exposants et ont subi malgré tout
l'effet de la crise les ventes étaient
parfois est difficile même si certains
ne manquaient pas d'originalité où il y
a elle et Mélanie pocket
tous les ans la magie de Noël s'installe
à Voisins le bretonneux à travers sa
centaine d'exposants le marché de Noël
de la ville et l'activité principale de
ces fêtes de fin d'année Christophe
Beaufils vient d'Ardèche et vient ici
tous les ans pour installer son stand
alors moi je vends des instruments de
musique du monde que je vais chercher en
général en Indonésie ou en Thaïlande et
au Népal et puis après les casse-têtes
que je ramène de Thaïlande mais le
marché de Noël c'est aussi l'occasion de
découvrir le travail des artisans locaux
comme celui de cette versaillesse qui
pratique la sculpture sur œuf ce sont
tout de vrais œufs depuis l'oeuf de
depuis l'oeuf de caille tout petit
jusqu'à l'oeuf d'autruche
en passant par loi la canne la poule
faisane la poule il me faut parfois et
le plus souvent plusieurs jours parce
que je ne peux pas terminer à neuf dans
une seule journée donc
voilà c'est quelque chose pour lequel on
ne compte pas vraiment s'entendre un
temps de travail pour lequel ces
artisans espèrent bien être récompensés
en réalisant des ventes ce qui devient
de plus en plus difficile au niveau
financier c'est pas hyper rentable parce
que on sent qu'il y a un problème de
crise les gens pas beaucoup d'argent les
gens regardent disent que c'est joli
mais même un petit sablier à 15 euros on
sent que
ils ont du mal pour sortir les sous
malgré la crise le marché de Noël reste
une bonne occasion de trouver des idées
de cadeaux originaux et pour les
retardataires il vous reste encore le
marché de Noël à Versailles jusqu'au 28
décembre
et en marche des marchés de Noël la fin
de l'année est aussi l'occasion pour les
communes de proposer des moments festifs
alors habitants exemple à
Magny-les-Hameaux et à la verrière
c'était également au cours du weekend
dernier
à La Verrière on est loin du marché de
Noël habituel ce marché-là est solidaire
15 associations ont fait le déplacement
les crayons de l'espoir vient de
Madagascar son but financer la scolarité
d'enfant malgache un enfant peut ainsi
être scolarisé avec trois euros par mois
ici chaque euro va directement à
l'association un marché solidaire donc
c'est un marché qui est vraiment
développé vers l'ouverture humaine et au
niveau de la solidarité des peuples qui
sont plus ou moins basés à l'étranger
des initiatives plébiscitées par le
public je suis venu parce que tout ce
qui est commerce équitable m'intéresse
et tout ce qui partage avec les autres
si je peux c'est très important parce
que grâce à cela ils vont vraiment
recevoir de l'argent par rapport à leur
à leur travail sur ce stand le festival
alternatiba Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
vient présenter ses actions et pratique
les prix libres un moyen de faire aussi
découvrir une autre consommation c'est
une manière de montrer qu'on peut qu'on
peut consommer autrement qu'on peut
aussi donner une seconde vie aux objets
Amani les hameaux tout autre ambiance
ici on a misé sur les activités
manuelles de quoi s'amuser tout en
apprenant autre
c'était au début de la télévision ils
utilisaient des machines comme ça ou il
y avait un miroir et on regardait le
miroir et on voyait l'image tournée on
avait l'impression que ça faisait
vraiment enfin un film j'ai pris un bout
de papier avec des dessins je les
connais sur une boîte de camembert et
j'ai mis un bâton et quand j'approche
l'oeil dans les trous et bah ça fait un
film et pour conclure cette belle
journée le Père Noël bien sûr et un feu
d'artifice pour profiter avec un peu
d'avance de la magie de Noël
Noël toujours solidarité aussi avec
l'opération de collecte de jouets
initiés parce qu'ibus savent après
l'appel au don et la collecte avec un
bus spécial à prêter par cette société
leur était à la distribution auprès des
associations partenaires une
distribution organisée dans une salle
prêtée par la mairie de La Verrière
cette année Yolaine Torres William elle
David ça va vite plus rapide alors n'a
pas une minute à perdre il récolte un
maximum de jouets pour les offrir à Noël
aux enfants défavorisés beaucoup de
poses jeux de société des vélos enfin de
vélo et puis des livres des livres
stimule un peu la lecture une vingtaine
d'associations partenaires profitent de
cette redistribution des jouets du bus
de Noël des jouets récoltés la semaine
dernière auprès des familles par le
réseau squibus est stocké ici au total
30 mètres cubes d'objets ont été
accumulés c'est autant de joueurs
récoltés que les années précédentes
c'est un nombre très très important des
milliers de jouets des livres des des
jeux il y a de très belles choses
Françoise et bénévoles à l'antenne du
Secours populaire de la verrière demain
à la maison du quartier du Bois de
l'Etang elle redistribuera ses jouets
lors d'une braderie donc là c'est la
foire d'empoigne parce que il y a
plusieurs associations et donc on essaie
de récupérer des jouets en une
quarantaine de minutes les salles sont
vides les voitures des bénévoles elles
plaiennent à craquer de jouer
quiigueront à coup sûr le Noël de
nombreux enfants
tout de suite sur tvfils le nouveau
numéro du 7 8 sociétés avec Catherine
zulato aujourd'hui avec ses invités il
sera question de la grogne des avocats
des notaires aussi contre le projet de
réforme Macron très bonne soirée